so I don't know and by the way I don't
think this is specifically gendered
actually because it happens with men as
well I think the reason why so many men
are afraid to commit or why so many
younger men are opposed to marriage it's
not just as simple as the laws and the
incentives that's that's a part of it
but it's also what they have seen
modeled right so if they've seen it man
there are millions of people who
legitimately have never seen like a
healthy male female relationship and
they project that outwards because they
think that that is just the norm and the
default and in some communities it
absolutely is that's the thing so I can
see how someone would grow up in that
and be like well it didn't work out for
my parents it didn't work out for my
friend's parents it didn't work so and
and like the quality of wife is just
like so much lower nowadays
I think the quality of both is lower to
be real
um I agree with you
um but I think that there are millions
and millions of men out there who are
not even
you know and some of this is from not
lacking encouragement I think one of the
hard I'll tell you what I think is one
of the hardest challenges for young men
right now I think one of the hardest
challenges for young men is being very
clear on what your purpose is as a man
because as we've said in the past your
role as a man was very simple whatever
people think of gender roles you can't
really argue that in the past and still
in many parts of the world if you're
growing up as a young man or a young
woman what your role is in society in
relationships and so on it's clear-cut
right it's very clear you're a man
you're going to be a provider you're
going to be a protector you're going to
be the one who is leading you're a woman
you're going to you're going to have
children you're going to be the primary
nurturer and caregiver you're going to
look after the home and so on yes you
can work a little yes the man can do
some of this but that those are your
roles right that's it whereas now
you've got
as I said an ever increasing number and
percentage of women who are they they've
they've they've got money they've got
their careers they've got their opinion
um you know they've got their
you know they've they've they've got all
that the stuff that a man would
typically historically provide or still
provide in many places it's like well
they've they've got that but they're
still the same biological attraction
triggers and imperatives so I think for
lots of young men they're kind of like
and they're they're literally being told
by women and by society and by the media
yeah oh you know we don't you know we
don't need men whatever single
independent woman I think there's so
many guys out there who are like okay
well what do I do do I turn into uh you
know do I just take take the take the
take the uh the Mac the macing route and
I just you know try to get laid with as
many women as possible do I you know
what what do I what do I do and I think
that a lot of young men don't know the
answer to that and I think that's why
from the Jordan Petersons to the Andrew
Tates you've seen this meteoric rise
with young men especially who are
looking for this meaning and purpose and
guidance to find some type of Direction
yeah I I still I think the girls are
worse than the guys like by a lot tell
me because men are still expected to
protect and provide and they still make
more money than girls by and large like
an overall not younger not in the 20s no
I'm talking about young men uh let's
let's say guys under 30. guys under 30
are not earning out earning women under
30. not anymore yeah yeah I guess you
could if you want to make the money I
just feel like they're they're still
expected to protect and provide they are
but like women aren't young or pure so
like that's what I'm saying like I think
it's like worse on the girls because
like the average age of first marriage
in the UK is what 31 or something like
that but yeah well well I'm saying this
is what I I'm not yeah we're saying the
same thing I'm saying this is the
challenge for young men it's like where
do you fit in right it's like okay you
can I could be a provider and a
protector but women are kind of saying
that they don't want or need that and
also I'm not if I look at the guys who
are doing well with women yeah they're
not necessarily doing the providing and
protecting thing so what am I don't
think Rich guys get chicks of course no
I'm not I'm not I'm not saying that but
most our most rich guys
necessarily doing that traditional thing
they're not oh no right exactly exactly
right so exactly right there they're
just running game so these young men are
like oh okay well that's that's the
solution yeah right I learned some game
yeah and maybe I go to the gym and you
know I make some type of money and I
just try to attract a lot of females and
have a lot of you know spin all these
plates and and and whatever it is but I
think that it's just it's confusing yeah
I think it's I think it's confusing for
women okay and it's confusing for men
too because it's men are the like okay
well what do
I think men are more reactionary because
because women sort of set the rules yeah
women sort of set the rules because
women are The Gatekeepers of sex and
intimacy right and so men are always
going to adapt and react to the females
in the environment right so that's why
the way
people date and have relationships
around the world in different countries
and communities is very very different
because if it's just like oh okay the
women are much more traditional and
chaste and conservative and they respond
well to a guy who's just got a good
character and can protect and provide
then men are like oh okay for me to get
a great woman I need to I need to do
that thing and be that thing yeah
whereas here or in the states
particularly in certain parts it's just
like okay well they're not responding to
that so I gotta I have to I now have to
change my strategy maybe in my head it
might be nice yeah I think it would be
nice to have that but that ain't working
here so I need to take this other route
yeah I mean
I I this is why birth control banned
birth control banned birth control tell
me more wow pearly's go okay
that's when everything's starting well
maybe with the boat
no because birth control made like
allowed girls to like go for those type
of guys before like there was more of a
consequence so you would you would think
twice before you sleep with the bad guy
or like the you know that archetype
right but now it's like oh there's a cop
out there's a bailout so you don't have
to think twice and so that that's why
why do you think we got all these baby
mamas with like the the kid the dad
that's got three different kids and
three different things
like and then they're also bailed out
because they're paid to be single
mothers like that that was next right so
it's like
I don't know I feel like every all the
world's problems started with birth
control all the world's problems yeah
yeah that's a big one yeah that's a big
one I mean because it all started with
the breakdown of the family and if you
look at if you look at that chart where
it talks about like the the rate that
women were taking oral contraceptives
with the divorce rate it's like the same
I'm sure you've seen it you're in the
yeah yeah and so it's like so is that
the welfare policies that's true I I
don't think it was one thing but I think
that started it interesting yeah and I'm
like if we got rid of birth control like
I feel like girls would be more
selective with who they slept with you
know we'd see families come back again
and get rid of the single mom policies
too I'm not okay maybe they're right
we need we need dictate dictator Pearl
in the in the building what do you think
is the biggest challenge that young
women face right now as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible